[Music]
jordan kicks us off in st louis missouri
jordan welcome to the show i don't have
the show here let me flip back there we
go jordan are you with us
yes yes thank you for taking my call yes
how can rachel and i help
hey just wondering if you guys had any
tips on
staying forward thinking in terms of
saving and doing everything
you know the way i should do it but also
being able to be present and enjoy the
moment
interesting so what's the question
what's the pain point there are you
you're budgeting right now currently
and you feel like you're not able to
enjoy it
well not necessarily it's just i feel
like you know saving and everything is
much more geared towards the future um
but i don't want to stay i want to be
able to enjoy the moment um
and enjoy the present
but also be able to
secure the future
so that can be reflected in your budget
do you have
things in your budget that involve
spending and vacations and buying things
that you want to buy
so i think it's more of just a general
mindset thing than
like budget specific
so it's like it's it's hard for me to
shift gears from like future future
future to enjoy the present
yeah and i think that there's a time and
a place for all that
that thinking and and dreaming i mean i
i'm probably more like you jordan i
probably enjoy the present
easier than i do thinking about the
future so
i just know with my personality then i'm
like okay i have to set time to make
sure that i'm looking at future goals
but i don't do that every day i mean
winston and i my husband and i will you
know we have we call it
dream dinners i don't know how cheesy
that is
might be a little cheesy but we'll just
go to dinner and be like okay if money
wasn't an option what would we do and
like some dinners we like take the
conversation down to
what if we would lived in montana on a
ranch and we're like off the grid like
it's that to
buying a new car i mean whatever it is
but it's like you just let yourself
dream and then out of that you really
see okay where do i want my future to go
and then yeah then you kind of set money
aside to get there and to hit that goal
but but i'm not sitting there every day
thinking oh what am i going to be when
i'm 50 oh gosh oh gosh oh gosh dude i'm
saying so i i feel like i do enjoy the
moment while having goals for the future
uh but i think there's a level of
probably contentment jordan too of the
present of just being excited and happy
where you are
um and then when the time comes that you
carve out specific intentional time to
really think about the future
then you're able to be in that mindset
but i think you can turn that mindset
off and you don't have to live in that
in a daily basis does that make sense
does that help
yeah absolutely i mean that's that's
great advice i do think i kind of get
stuck in that mindset sometimes and it
produces a lot of anxiety so i
appreciate that what helped me jordan
was having a good healthy mix of
short-term and long-term goals so an
example me and my wife we want to go to
europe later this year that's a
short-term goal we want to save up for
we also know we want to save up to buy a
upgraded house later down the road that
could be a few years from now but we
also have things that are happening this
weekend that are in the budget that
we're saving up for and so i think
having that mix makes you feel like i'm
not just thinking about the future yeah
and it helps when you're doing the thing
for the weekend that you're present in
the moment in the weekend and you're
like hey we planned on going out to a
nice dinner with friends so when you're
enjoying your nice dinner
you actually enjoy the dinner and
thinking about the moment you're not
thinking oh gosh i gotta fund my 401k to
make sure i have this amount of money
you know what i mean don't let yourself
go there because i do think jordan to
your point that can be unhealthy and it
steals
the joy of the moment that you're in if
you're constantly just thinking about
the future and the past like i know
people that live in the past
and it's the either the regret or the oh
those were great years if we could just
go right and there's a time and a place
to go back but i think that there's a
healthy mentality to be in the present
and to enjoy it so i think you're on the
right track jordan um i think it's a
great question are you married jordan
uh no i'm not i'm single i'm 28 years
old okay what i would do if i'm if i'm
in your shoes i'm going to find some
friends that i think are wise and that i
want to hang out with and go kind of
dream a little bit with them and use
them as accountability and use them as
kind of that
bounce bouncing launch pad to go hey
let's have some fun i want to budget for
some things in the short term i want to
budget for some things in the long term
maybe they'll give you some ideas of
what that could look like
yeah
all right i hope that helps thanks
jordan appreciate the call man you know
it'd be an interesting i'm just doing
this on the fly if it works it works
it's friday it's all live okay if you
there are single people out there
call in
because i do want to have a discussion
about this quote unquote like
accountability partner so i say that
because we talk about that a lot at
ramsey if you're not married i kind of
hate that word can i say that to you
yeah accountability feels like i don't
know i agree it feels like old youth
group of like i don't know
so find a friend that you like
and the idea then the reason we say this
is because you don't need to do life
alone and when you're single
you know it's isolating all of your
decisions are up to you everything from
buying groceries to making sure the oil
is fixed in the car
if you have a car that has oil fell a
tesla owner there wow right there don't
leave me hanging oh i'm sorry
but what i'm saying is like you're not
sorry george
the
the
decision making you're making it in a
vacuum in so many areas of life so
having a person that walks beside you
um to bounce those especially those big
decisions with yeah is really important
when you're starting out budgeting
having someone that's wise with money to
be like hey i just want you to look at
this and make sure i'm not missing
anything crazy and it's a very organic
natural conversation i feel like
sometimes it can sound so real don't
walk up to someone go will you be my
accountability partner and see my budget
every single month can we meet on the
15th at 3 o'clock
but but i do if you're single out there
and you have this person in your life
and it's working well i want you to call
in because i want to talk about it
because i think there's a really
great way to do it
um that is
very helpful
and is possible but it's not um overly
for you know that it's not just like
awkward or something wow well there it
is rachel just opened up a singles theme
hour so give us a call triple eight
eight two five
five two two five let's talk about this
is good because two i'm going to keep
adding on here because i got married
young so winston has all i mean i've had
a husband for
the whole basically my whole adult life
yeah
so when i talk about it i know friends
that have done it and you know and i
have a friend and she's great at having
someone in her corner um but i always
like to hear real life how this works
for people day in and day out and what
it really looks like tactically so but
for you
did you ever have a good friend that
that was that before oh yeah because
there's friends that have been mentors
to me that i look up to a lot of people
really show them your budget yeah we
talk to you know the ins and outs of
money especially in a place like this at
ramsey i know it's very normal for us to
talk about money and so it's it's fun
it's almost fun it's like a sport to us
but what's in your budget this month how
are you saving up for that how'd you do
that you know we kind of it's like
inside baseball here at ramsey but it is
true when you get outside of the ramsey
bubble you're like oh people don't talk
about money right right it's unless
they're making fun of how you know
screwed they are with their student
loans and
you know car payment